aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
au château de Blois au troisième étage
là où se trouve les réserves alors ici
les réserves de meubles mais en tout il
y a 35000 pièces qui sont conservées
dans ce château royal Morgan lecareux
vous êtes chargé de maintien restaurée
expliquez-nous les plus anciennes elle
date des rois les plus anciennes pièces
de vos collections
qui sont aujourd'hui au château de Blois
ne date pas de l'époque où le château
était royal et où la cour qui était
itinérante transportait son mobilier et
donc ces œuvres d'art également par
exemple ça c'est ça date de quelle
époque c'est une pièce importante
donc oui c'est une des pièces anciennes
et importante de nos collections de
mobilier alors elle est là pour être
présentée au public elle est là pour
être cachée du public comment ça
s'organise elle est là pour être
conservée c'est à dire qu'elle fait
partie de nos collections et notre
mission en tant que musée c'est
justement de les préserver
35000 pièces ça paraît ça paraît énorme
l'histoire de toutes ces collections
puisqu'il y a aussi bien des vêtements
des meubles des œuvres d'art au milieu
du 19e
siècle le vote décide de créer un musée
qui n'existait pas du tout donc elle
fait appel à la population donc va
donner les gays elle va acheter aussi
quelques pièces mais donc la première
fond de la collection c'est c'est donc
de particulier et c'est pour ça que
c'est très hétéroclite donc on a
effectivement des objets d'art donc du
mobilier des tableaux des sculptures
mais on a aussi effectivement des
costumes on a de l'ethnographie on a des
arts extra-occidentaux on a de
l'animismatique du lapidaire enfin on a
vraiment tout type de collection au
château alors vous avez parlé des
costumes on va s'y intéresser de près
puisqu'effectivement c'est une des
collections que que vous entretenez je
vous propose de découvrir la
restauration de ses vêtements qui ont
été délégués ici au château royal de
Blois
chemise d'homme culotte à la française
cravate Coiff
je tiens gorge chemise de nuit
des tissus tout simplement déguisement
Bonnie bonnet Coiff au troisième étage
de l'aile Gaston d'Orléans Clémence
Denis étudiante en histoire de l'art à
en charge la conservation de 2500
costumes des vêtements stockés là depuis
plus de 3 siècles c'est un fond
d'archives mais en tissu c'est souvent
des familles importantes de Blois qui
ont légué leur pièce
les plus belles et donc les robes les
vêtements de mariage sont parmi les plus
précieux dans une famille et c'est pour
ça que souvent ils étaient légués au
château
pour bien archiver tout ses vêtements il
faut les reconditionner un travail rendu
indispensable après 300 ans passés dans
des cartons
liés au conditionnement et au fait
qu'elle était repliée sur elle-même
et puis on voit qu'il y a des tâches des
déchirures
avant de se réendormir pour des
centaines d'années dans une boîte en
plastique alvéolée le tissu est déplié
inspecté et référencé un travail
minutieux qui transforme un gilet ou une
robe en archive ça va vraiment du 18ème
au 20e on voit vraiment l'évolution en
fait du costume et ça nous permet de
garder un témoignage de la façon dont
les gens pouvaient se vêtir au 19e
siècle en l'occurrence à partir des
années 1900 on retrouve plus du tout ce
type d'encolure le haut de la robe donc
qui est détaché de la détaché de la jupe
c'est vraiment une robe en deux parties
ça on le retrouve on retrouve plus tôt
aujourd'hui on s'est totalement un
corset enfin c'est hérité du corset
depuis toujours je savais que je voulais
travailler voilà dans la conservation
préventive des
œuvres d'art mais vraiment pour moi le
costume le textile ça a vraiment cette
fragilité que et cette spécificité que
n'ont pas voilà les tableaux ou
finalement on a on a plus l'habitude ou
c'est là c'est vraiment c'est sur chaque
pièce ou chaque pièce est vraiment
unique donc chaque travail sur chaque
pièce sera aussi unique et c'est ça que
je trouve vraiment vraiment génial photo
et référencement de ses costumes vont
être mis en ligne sur internet désormais
les chercheurs du monde entier auront
accès à la mode tourangelle
voilà comme vous l'avez vu pour les
costumes il faut vous dire que c'est
l'ensemble des œuvres d'art l'ensemble
des meubles que Morgane lecareux vous
êtes chargé de maintien restauré dites
moi dans votre travail de conservation
restauration qu'est-ce qui vous anime
je pense que ce qui me plaît le plus
c'est la manipulation
d'avoir le privilège en fait immense de
pouvoir obtenir dans les mains des
œuvres anciennes prestigieuses avec une
histoire très riche voilà c'est ça qui
me plaît le plus dans le travail ici au
château royal de Blois finalement
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il restera
et ben c'est compliqué à dire mais
il restera certainement certaines choses
par exemple les costumes la
reconditionnement va permettre
certainement de préserver leur durée
d'existence encore un petit peu et c'est
justement de d'apporter sa petite pierre
à l'édifice et d'être un peu le témoin
voilà les collections qui étaient là il
y a des siècles et qui seront là des
siècles après nous et nous on est en
transmet et donc on est deux passages
finalement dans ce château et ses
collections des collections que vous
pouvez partiellement découvrir tout au
long de l'année lorsque vous visitez les
différentes ailes du château royal de
Blois